Feel it.
And I think we learn about ourselves through a specialty self.
Well,
any kind of adversity,
you know,
look,
I'm coming off of,
uh,
being evacuated from the fires,
which was a for me not that difficult,
you know,
um,
I'm not poor.
I got a hotel,
I brought my family to the hotel,
we got safe,
got my dog to the,
to the podcast studio and everybody's all right,
you know,
but for those firefighters,
I mean 12 hour shifts battling the blaze for people who lost their homes.
Some of them tried to save it.
There was a story about a guy in Malibu,
the climbed on top of his roof with a hose and tried to fight off the fire and
he got severe burns and he's in the hospital and I mean,
it's raining ash and,
and,
and these chunks of fucking fire on people,
these embers,
they're falling from the sky and this guy's trying to save his house.
I mean,
that guy literally went through the fires.
He'll be a different person after this.
No question.
Um,
we've been in something of a reality drought.
The number of people who have very little relationship to reality.
I mean,
you know,
I used to live in Cambridge,
Massachusetts and you'd,
you'd come in from Boston and there would be the science at freshed killed
chicken,
like no bones bad at man fresh killed chicken,
but like chicken mcnuggets nobody quite knows what,
what,
what part of the chicken is a mcnugget,
right?
It's just some abstraction that comes to you.
And so I think we've gotten very divorced.
They're all,
all of these layers of indirection between us and the world.
And when a fire happens,
it's so overwhelming.
We were just choking on the,
the SF smoke,
uh,
in the bay area.
There's it,
it just,
it gets real after having been unreal for a very long time.
It's unavoidable.
It makes you,
it makes you buck up.
Like you got to get out of there.
Like we got evacuated Thursday at two 30 in the morning.
We,
we were looking up,
we were like,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Like it,
I don't give a shit what you leave behind.
Just go keep your body and go everything else either.
It's either replaceable or you don't really need it that much anyway,
just fucking get out of there.
And when you see that fire raging over those hills and helicopters dropping
water on it and then another house explodes because the gas line gets hit,
it's just you,
you,
I've saw that,
you see that you go,
oh,
there's,
this is not enough people in the world to save you.
There's not enough fucking firefighters or cops.
There's too many houses as too many people and a bunch of these houses are going
to go,
you've got to get the fuck out of there.
And um,
but there's a certain,
I was with,
uh,
a bunch of my friends from my neighborhood and my friend Tom Segura and his
wife,
we all stayed at the same hotel and we felt we've,
there was like a tangible sense of community.
Well,
this is,
I'm,
I love this point.
Let's imagine you go for a wedding and they house you with your third cousins.
People you barely know.
If you're lucky enough that the sewage system breaks and like stuff is leaking
out of the ceiling and you guys all have to do heroic,
crazy stuff to save the house,
you're going to be closer to your third cousin.
You are,
you know,
do your uncle.
Right.
And this is this very strange feature of the world that,
eh,
kind of a random arrival of diversity is very often what bonds you to some
particular human being.
And if you avoid adversity in groups your whole life,
you probably don't realize that a,
you're never fully activated as a human being or particularly,
you know,
if,
if men I think don't form groups that in some sense fight or battle or contest
together.
So there's this very weird fact that apparently humans are the only species that
organize,
uh,
contests in teams.
Um,
you know,
this is an intrinsic feature of being human contests.
Yeah.
Do other animals have any contest?
Well,
just stuff they've sparked chimps,
you know,
we'll,
uh,
have these incredible raiding parties in a very methodical,
and they'll,
they'll attack somebody else,
but I don't think that they practice it.
It's like,
okay,
your red team,
chimp and your B team chimp,
what were the only ones that do stuff like that that can communicate,
right?
Like dolphins can communicate,
but they don't do stuff like that.
Right?
Or you have individual sparring,
like you'll have two bears learning to play with each other.
Um,
because it's safer to play with your brother and childhood than it is to just
suddenly show up against some big ass bear and have to compete for females.